quiero que me digan cuántos bisabuelos
tenemos cada quien
quiero que me mencionen el nombre de sus
ocho bisabuelos
se lo saben
que les provoca no sé verse qué
emociones genera no conocerlo
pero no se preocupen porque no son
problemas de ustedes
es un problema de ellos
que no se preocuparon nunca en construir
un legado
imagínense
de manera sorpresiva una enfermedad
terminal les llega
y habrán conseguido hasta este momento
y quedan conformes con lo que tiene
qué le dirían a su niño interior
que le contestaría de lo que le
prometieron que iban a llegar a ser
imaginemos por un momento quién pueda
hacerlo dibuje un círculo
dibuja un círculo y divide a las 24
horas de su día
y digan cuánto tipo gastan en
alimentarse en descansar en trabajar en
estar en la escuela en el traslado
leer
en las redes sociales
y del otro lado
pongan sus metas
sus metas para este año
pero también las metas para dentro de
cinco años diez años veinte años
y ahora con toda certeza
díganme
cuanta parte de su tiempo están
dedicando a sus metas
para mí construir un legado
es encontrar tu pasión pero sobre todo
respetar tu tiempo
soy carol orensana y esta es mi historia
terminaba yo la primaria
y recuerdo muy bien ese evento donde me
premiaron porque fui el mejor alumno de
la primaria
esta alegría el diploma calidad de
acuerdo con un trofeo bastante grande
y ahora yo el centro del evento
pero también hubo sacrificio en todo eso
porque recuerdo ya veces mantenía yo
recreo
porque tenía que estar en oficina de la
directora en la hora del recreo escuela
de monjas por cierto
viendo como los demás niños jugaban y yo
tiene que estar estudiando porque se
acercaban los concursos estatales
y recuerdo también que terminaba yo la
escuela y salía iba yo a casa bañaba me
comía y otra vez regresaba a la escuela
a seguir preparándome para los concursos
yo no sé si se compensaba de esa alegría
que cuando te entregan el trofeo con ese
sacrificio
luego viene la prepa y me salto la
secundaria no por otra cosa que también
fui bien estudiante
buena estudiante y bien a la prepa y ha
vivido circunstancias importantes en mí
primero nuevamente fui la persona de los
dieces
puedo presumir que no tengo en un 9 en
el 1er
y entonces eso era también como un tema
de alegría pero significó también
sacrificio
recuerdo en una ocasión que mis padres
me decían
puede ser el ejemplo de tus hermanos
no te das cuenta y te preguntas
sinceramente y dices es en serio que
alguien tiene que ser el ejemplo de los
hermanos es en serio que todos tienen
que ser iguales o seguir un patrón de
'la u' de alguno yo no lo creo
y viví también otra circunstancia en la
prepa
tenía yo que definir hacia dónde me iba
tiene que definirse a estudiar el área
de químicos biólogos físicos matemáticos
o ciencias sociales
y ustedes podrían decir ah eso puede ser
fácil
en un tema de legado familiar yo crecí
con mi familia materna una abuela
materna
mi madre ciudad radiología un tío tenía
un consultorio dental el otro había
tenido la carrera trunca de medicina mi
abuela era jefe de enfermeras de una
parte importante de un estado en su
momento tuvo una farmacia y un pequeño
hospital
ahí crecí
imagínense lo que significaba para mí el
tema de la medicina
cuando este pequeño mi abuela siempre me
presentaba como el es carlos mi doctor y
mi futuro doctor y donde estuviéramos
poseerá el doctor
y cuando yo estaba en la prepa y decido
no estudiar medicina
y cuando dije no no quiero que esto
ya quiero dedicarme a las ciencias
sociales fue un tema de ruptura de
ruptura para la ilusión de mi abuela
y entonces con el paso del tiempo
también te preguntas si hubiera pasado
si bien estudiado medicina
seguramente también sería un buen médico
no lo sé
lo que sí se escribe ha estado viviendo
el sueño de ella y no el mío
que hubiera sido un legado que era que
ellos querían en el niño
entonces cuáles son los parámetros para
medir el éxito en la vida calificaciones
trofeos dinero propiedades cuáles son
los parámetros
para mí el principal parámetro es
encontrar tu pasión
para mi pasión no significa sacrificio
ni desgarrar te pasión es encontrar tu
felicidad realmente hacer lo que te
gusta eso creo que debe ser el verdadero
valor o estándar del fbi
saben qué pasaría si desde pequeños nos
enseñan a ir construyendo un legado
lleva tres cosas principales
primero nos ahorraríamos tiempo no
estaríamos divagando
segundo nos enfocaríamos mejor a lo que
realmente nos hace felices
y tercero disfrutaríamos el camino
cuando hablo de construir un legado no
me refiero a los grandes personajes de
la historia
a martin luther king y elton john y a
cantinflas de la madre teresa
y juan pablo
mercier o algo más cercano voy a citar
el caso de tres niños mexicanos
tres niños mexicanos que no rebasan ni
los once años una de ellos estos chicos
y un instituto de ciencias de la unam la
reconoció como la científica más joven
cia panetta diez años la niña construyó
un panel solar
o como carlos lópez un niño oaxaca de la
selección de básquetbol triqui que un
entrenador francés lo descubre y se lo
lleva a jugar europa su equipo gana el
torneo y él es nombrado el mejor jugador
también 12 años
o como carlos sotomayor un niño que a
sus 9 años estaba estudiando un
diplomado de bioquímica pre industria
farmacéutica y fue el alumno con mejores
calificaciones
con mejores calificaciones a sus 9 años
a eso me refiero con su ilegal y
construir legado entonces no tiene nada
que ver con la edad
se acuerdan de aquella famosa frase que
regularmente en toda la fiesta no la
defiende y que quiere ser de grande
ya tenemos que hacer entonces
lleve a 5 puntos primero visión
y queremos lograr hacia dónde vamos
cuando nuestro sueño cuál es nuestra
causa cómo nos vemos en 5 10 20 años
y queremos llegar a ser es importante
marcarlo para entender hacia dónde vamos
y luego la pasión que como les decía yo
tiene que ser ese reconocimiento de lo
que está haciendo feliz que te hace
feliz que te mueve que te motiva
yo le digo a la gente que trabaja
conmigo o sea para mí la puntualidad es
algo importante porque me demuestra
pasión porque sé que si llegas puntual
es porque te gusta trabajar acá esto que
disfrutas estar acá
el otro respeto
respecto a lo que tú estás decidiendo
respecto a tu vida a tu proyecto
respetarte
y les pongo una pregunta aquí en el
bolton
quién de ustedes está estudiando algo
porque sus papás quieren que estudies
tiene ustedes está estudiando algo
porque no les queda otra opción más que
estudiar esa carrera
o quien de ustedes como papá le están
imponiendo sus hijos sus deseos no
cumplidos
hay que respetarnos
visión acción respeto gratitud también
hay que ser agradecidos
agradecidos con los maestros
decía uno de mis maestros hay que tener
espalda de hombre para soportar el
precio de la gratitud no cualquiera lo
hace
y lo otro punto importante no cualquiera
lo valora
y el quinto punto es la congruencia
la congruencia en todos los sentidos
realmente respetar lo que decimos y
hacemos
este es un tema central
yo puedo presumir algo en este momento
vivir dejando legado
me encanta leer y creo que ese tema ya
lo inserte mis hijos
carlos citar la que son los mayores de
mis hijos ley no sé cuántos libros al
año
perecieron anoche bueno carla que ésta
ya no tanto porque tiene novio no me la
distraen un poco
y carlos como diego 12 años metido en
las ipads en los teléfonos hace con un
mes llega a mí sé quiero un curso de
lectura rápida que va
y lucía la pequeña lucía de cuatro años
y no se duerme si no le leen un libro
y cuando digo que no se duerme es no se
duerme hasta que el aliento
este tema de la congruencia y del
respecto y de la visión y de la pasión
también nos hace dependemos un poco y
entender lo que dice carlos castán y en
su libro
en las enseñanzas de don juan dice para
un crecimiento el hombre que le cuatro
enemigos
el primero es el miedo
aquel que te paraliza que te moviliza y
no te permite visualizar realmente lo
que eres capaz no te atreves a dar el
siguiente paso
y sé que cuando se vence ese miedo
cuando tienes claridad
claridad de entender quién eres tu
claridad de entender tus escenarios sus
fortalezas y entonces te controla sin
miedo y lo controlas porque sabes que
siempre va a estar allí y no tiene que
paralizar te tiene que ser un motor
incluso
cuando eso lo entiendes es porque tienes
claridad y la claridad que es buena por
supuesto porque te permite visualizar lo
que debemos hacer para crecer
pero la claridad empieza a tergiversar
se cuando no entendemos realmente para
que la queremos cuando creemos que es el
dominio del escenario nos lleva a ser
vanidosos incluso
y altaneros los sabelotodos
y cómo se controla el tema de la
claridad
cuando te das cuenta que tienes poder
cuando ese miedo controlado con esa
claridad desbordada ya la tienes en tus
manos
y entonces tienes el poder
y empiezas a hacer cosas y empiezas a
decidir empiezas a valorar lo que tienes
y empiezas a construir más y más
pero el poder dice castañeda también se
puede convertir en un enemigo
cuando te vuelves autoritario autócrata
cuando no sabes controlarlo
y entonces le preguntan y hay una forma
de tener el poder
dice quizá no pero puede llegar un
momento y puede llegar una etapa del
hombre que sigue
y aparte y aparece entonces el cuarto
enemigo es la vejez
y entonces te quedas paralizado
y sé lo peor de la vejez
es el enemigo más cruel incluso
dice es que puede ser un evento
momentáneos y nosotros así queremos
lo peor de la vejez es querer descansar
hay una forma de combatirlo ya que está
en movimiento constante
y dice
este estos cuatro enemigos
el miedo la claridad el poder y la vejez
nos pueden llevar a un crecimiento
en lo particular cuando yo digo que
tenía la visión y la pasión y este tema
de respeto y agradecimiento y entendía
en mis enemigos y me sentía yo en la
cima
triunfando y corriendo y comiendo el
mundo porque he sido conferencista en
diferentes países
y sin darte cuenta el éxito puede llevar
con una zona de confort sin darnos
cuenta
hace 6 años
la vida me siento nuevamente
hace 6 años sufrí dos fraudes económicos
y un divorcio y vivir la enfermedad mi
hermano en un cáncer terminal
y no obstante eso hace seis años
un día amanezco con 14 pesos a la bolsa
y te das cuenta y empezar todo este
control que es extender a tu vida
nuevamente puede llegar a afectar
cada año en la oficina me siento con los
jóvenes como este trabajo
y les pregunto cuál es la palabra que
definió el año que está terminando
y muchos me dicen enseñanza crecimiento
alegría felicidad cambio transformación
y su padre reconocer que fue nuestro año
pero después me di cuenta estábamos
siendo como la causa
y esta misma pregunta la tengo que hacer
pero la tengo que hacer en enero en
diciembre
y el dinero les pregunte
no cuál es la palabra que define el año
anterior
si no les pregunté cuál es la palabra
que va a definir este año
qué quieres lograr este año
con tu palabra como guía y así ya vamos
a ser menos
el hecho que la vida me sentara
y me dijera él
no todo tampoco es como crees
me puse a reflexionar inscribir dos
grandes frases en oficina en las paredes
de los tiempos una dice encuentra tu
pasión y sigue la
porque los chavos deben sentirse muy a
gusto y encontrar su pasión es la
segunda dice hagamos que la historia nos
recuerde porque debo recordarle los
diarios porque estoy trabajando ahí que
quieren llegar
y luego en una tarde de reflexión
dije tengo que empezar a dejar algo y
ese tema de crisis me sacudió hoy el
legado no solamente tiene que ser
individual el legado tienes que hacer
algo por los demás también y construí un
programa de formación política que se
llama inicia nos estamos formando
jóvenes en la primera generación fueron
25 la segunda fueron 60 hoy puedo
presumir que estos jóvenes 7 han sido
premiados en washington
y uno de ellos es el coordinador
nacional de un programa de la
organización de estados américanos
la vida te siento y creo que hay una
pregunta muy importante que resolver
siempre
que es que queremos dejar atrás cuando
cerremos por última vez la puerta de
nuestra vida
así que seamos el mejor bisabuelo
hagamos las cosas bien y hagamos que la
historia nos recuerde muchas gracias
[Aplausos]